chuck
hey neil we're gonna do this again it is
time one of these explainer videos i
love it so how about this one
have you ever wondered how much air
weighs i i've never really thought like
how much does
air weigh how could you ever measure air
how could you get it on a scale
yes and easy it turns out it's really
easy so here's how you need to think
about it
okay so you might remember from our
water tower
explainer video maybe we can put a link
to it
in the bottom here in the water tower
you might remember there are more
retainer hoops lower down
then higher up because the deeper down
in the water you go
the greater is the pressure and so it
has to hold
the the structure needs more more
stability
in the lower sections than in the upper
sections
so the hoops that sustain wooden water
towers on the rooftops of practically
every building in new york city if you
live in a town that has a single water
tower
you don't you got to visit new york to
know what i'm talking about
you're being cheated
[Laughter]
they're all drinking from the same water
yeah you're getting a community water
tower
you know what i mean you're supposed to
like you know it should just be on top
of your building just your water your
building
so you have more hoops as you get lower
because as you get lower the pressure of
the water increases
by the way in one of the episodes of
watchmen
on hbo one of the later episodes
they go up in one of their funky
helicopter airplanes
to put out fire and they do that by
knocking over a water tower on the roof
of a building and the water spills into
the building puts out the fire
very clever okay cool however the water
tower
had equally spaced hoops on it so
only you would have picked that up so i
knew it was not an authentically filmed
water tower someone drew that
and didn't know the physics of it okay
so cgi water tower
cgi water tower nice physics illiterate
cgi water tower
so by the same reasoning
the lower you are in the atmosphere the
heavier the atmosphere becomes
all right that makes sense so we don't
think of it that way we think of it as
air pressure
right so you're at sea level air
pressure is about in
in english units 15 pounds
per square inch okay that's the pressure
at sea level
you go up to mountain tops it drops you
keep going higher up it gets less and
less and less and less
right okay let's get a handle on what
that pressure means and i'll tell
you here you go you ready to say
it's 15 pounds per square inch that's
the same thing as me saying
take a column of air right one
square inch and cross it one inch by one
inch okay
and take that column and extend it up to
the
outer reaches of the atmosphere okay
now remove all other air and you just
have this one column
right and put that on a scale that'll
weigh 15 pounds
okay so that's what it's talking about
yes it's it's not like the it's the
air from here to
all the way with where there where there
is no more air you're at the very outer
reaches
correct take a cookie cut to kick a
cookie cutter and you
go all the way down and if you were to
if if you were to pull that out extract
that that's 15 pounds
put that on a scale it'll weigh 15
pounds wow
now here's what's interesting every
square inch is that
okay every square inch so 15 pounds here
15 miles here here here
all around now the re the reason why
you don't experience it that way you say
oh my gosh i can't get up out of bed i'm
feeling the weight of the air
because pressure in a fluid
such as water and such as air a fluid is
something that takes the shape of its
container okay that's a fluid
among other properties but it's that's
one of them so
the way that manifests in a fluid is
that the pressure is in every
direction at that location
so you have air pushing down on you on
the bed but you also have 15 pounds per
square inch pushing up on you
in all directions so therefore
all those forces are neutralized and you
can just move through it
without feeling the burden of the weight
of the air
nice okay so now
here's where it gets fun if i take a
suction cup
and plunge it onto the surface of a
table
thereby removing the air on the other
side of that cup
that previously was in balance with the
rest of the air around it
if i plunge that down and now i say pick
up the suction cup
you it you can't it's and you say it's
sucked
it's sucking i can't because no
it doesn't because you don't have the
counterbalance there's no counterbalance
and so i can tell you exactly how much
it is sucking
okay add up how many square inches
are on the surface of that suction cup
let's say there's 10 of them 10 let's
say there's 10 square inches
is a small suction cup 3 by 3. 10 square
inches right
so how much total atmospheric weight is
sitting on top of that
150 pounds you have to pick you have to
lift it with lifting
hundreds for 150 pounds and then you'll
lift it off the table
wow that's pretty cool that's how
pretty so it's really they're not such
so suction is not
itself a thing it really isn't they're
not sucking anything
it's not sucking anything it's the
weight of the atmosphere pressing down
on it you're trying to lift that weight
up
the bigger the suction cup the more
upward force you're going to have to
apply
to counterbalance the weight of the
atmosphere pressing down on it
that's how and why suction cups work
yeah depression cups that's what they
shipped depression cups i like that
minus the psychological dimension of it
but yes well it's just like just like
regular depression that makes it very
hard to get up
[Music]
so um so just next time you're
picking and by the way it would work in
any direction okay because
right horses so you can have a second
cup from below as well
trying to pull right down so you're
relying
oh by the way if you made any pocket of
air get inside the suction cup
it's over it's over at that point it's
over at that point
so that's why you need smooth surfaces
so that air doesn't leak in
to counterbalance the upward force that
you're trying to
to invoke so so this is
um so that's when you want to think of
how much air weighs
just toss a suction cup on a smooth
table and that'll tell you
exactly that's really cool and that is
you can also now that being said let's
get back to your altered state
question that you posed the universe um
back
when you were experimenting in college
right yes that's what it was
that's what it was sure exactly yes you
can ask what is the weight of the air
inside of a box and it's not that much
you know um could be you know a few
ounces
um well about the weight of a nickel i
think is the weight of the air inside of
a suitcase
wow so it's not nothing it's not nothing
it's not nothing but consider
when you're weighing things on earth
you're not saying well let me get the
air out of it first before i do so
no of course not you're just not saying
that right um
so because generally what you're
weighing is so much more than the weight
of the air that's in it
you don't concern yourself with this but
in precision measurements
that matters so you can ask the question
how would you weigh
a helium balloon
interesting well
i'm gonna have to smoke something and
get back together
that's how you get access to these deep
questions yeah right
that's how that's how i access those
neural net pathways
so is it a negative weight no it's not a
negative weight the difference is
that by the way all fluids
also have a buoyant force associated
with them
okay so you can ask how much
do you weigh you know on earth you can
stand on a scale
uh how much do you weigh in the water
how much do you weigh you will weigh
less less right i don't know how much
you know
whatever depending how fat you are
basically but uh that'll depend on how
much less you weigh
by walking in water water has a buoyant
force
right and humans have
depending on what your mixture is of
muscle and fat
you are slightly less buoyant
or slightly more boring or rather
slightly more dense than border or
slightly less dense so some people float
some people sink
right okay so we have approximately the
density of water itself
which means we're practically weightless
in a swimming pool
okay nice practically weightless all
right
so um and by the way a cork
which when you let go in the air falls
to the ground you let go of it in the
water it floats to the top
right right so the cork is to water what
a helium balloon is to air
right the healing blue wants to float to
the top but you know the cork has weight
absolutely you just say we'll just pull
it out of the water of course it doesn't
have zero weight put it pull it out of
the water we'll weigh it
well if i want your true weight i have
to pull you out of the atmosphere
the atmosphere being a fluid has a
buoyant force
operating on you and so
what do you how do you is there any way
around that yeah you take the helium
blue put it in an evacuated chamber
right where there is no buoyant force
and then it'll just sit there on the
scale
right and then you can actually get its
weight you can get it wait that's right
that's cool too
so so uh so so there you have it chuck
and and by the way the atmosphere on
venus is a hundred times heavier than
the atmosphere here
you know i'm happy i'm not there well
here's what would happen
if i just plunked you down there you
would just flatten and flatten out yeah
because the gases inside of you are in
equilibrium with this atmosphere
and you'd go there you just that that'd
be the end of chuck you could possibly
slowly adjust okay under such high
pressure as more gases can be
dissolved in your body this is how you
get the bends coming out from
from right of the high pressure deep sea
diving
and you come too fast your blood
releases
gases and it gets caught up in your
joints and things and it's not good for
you
um so uh so the pressure thing
it's i think there's not enough
talked about when it's it's something we
live with yeah yeah
so chuck i can't quickly think of this
in metric but
another way to think about it without
using any any
measures of it at all is if you get a a
a suction cup that might be
i don't know a typical child suction cup
or the kind of suction cup they use to
carry glass
yeah um that you see that when the glass
installed when you have yeah the kind of
glass that always gets broken by a car
as two men are carrying it across the
street
yes yes that glass that glass right
there
okay those suction cups um those are
holding on
with the weight of an average uh
human adult okay wow
so a slightly heavy woman a slightly
lighter man around there
a suction cup about this size is
held to a surface by the weight of an
adult human
and that's really just the removal of
air that's all it really is
that's all it is that's so cool man that
is cool
so there you go chuck uh well i'm off to
climb a building now
thanks got got my sexy cups ready
black spiderman what's out
[Laughter]
no somebody gonna shoot your ass to [__]
you
oh that's hilarious dead black spiderman
ah that's so funny all right
this has been star talk stuff you
thought you knew
and chuck always good to have you always
a pleasure neil degrasse tyson
bidding you to keep